he is the goat himself from the
University of Michigan as well as
Oakland in Green Bay he is none other
than Charles Woodson how are you Charles
I'm doing well so we just showed a clip
of you with T b12
I mean what is it like with hold on
let's start with this way first time you
met Tom Brady was wine Charles there to
be 1995 hmm it's been a long time man
but I mean we were freshmen together at
Michigan so it's been a long time ago
rich and now I mean what so what does it
like to see him 24 years later after
what you and he you accomplished and he
is still accomplishing Charles yeah you
know it was great to you know see him
and you know spend a little time with me
it's been a couple of years you know
since I really you know was able to just
sit down and chat with him for a little
while but it's just crazy you know to
you know see him walk in that door you
know as a six-time Super Bowl champion I
mean you know people are always asking
me all the time what did you see in Tom
Brady in school you know did you ever
think he'd be this good and you know
it's just crazy to come you know to be
here 20 you know four years later and
him you know being a six-time Super Bowl
champ so yeah it was funny just sitting
there sitting chat with him a little bit
you know just trying to get inside his
mind a little bit so and in terms of
getting inside his mind it seems from
what I have heard you tried to get
inside his kitchen a little bit where
you did you bring up the Tuck rule with
him moment Charles did that actually
happen or will we see that tonight on on
epics this evening sir yeah yeah yeah
you kind of got it you got to stay tuned
the seed you know what happens but yeah
you know what kind of I started it off I
started it off with that so that was
your opener Charles
that was my hello how often do you do
you hear about that charles woodson
about the tuck room yes sir
man you know rich I feel like I hereby
the Tuck rule everyday I feel like it
comes up somehow some way and some
conversation you know the Tuck rule you
know I mean especially you know when you
run into Raiders fans on a daily basis
they'll always say it was still a fumble
so I mean you can never ever get away
from that play I'm sure I like hearing
about that place you know for the rest
of my life so all the time rich well I
know you commented on it on Twitter so I
want to get it fresh right here we had
Doug freshly minted Pro Football Hall of
Famer Ty Law on the show recounting that
night here let's uh pause our chat for a
moment and stroll down this memory lane
and get your comment on the other side
yeah it was funny because after the game
you know normally every time I play
against Charles we meet up in the
parking lot and you know just chop it up
but after that game I'm coming you know
by his busses I'm like work well Charles
you know I mean gonna come all this boy
so I seen when he came up I was like
would he walk straight on the bus so in
typical tile off fashion I'm gonna go
and save me come talk to me imagine it's
just a game even though to go to the
Super Bowl so I walked on on the bus on
the front of the bus
not like would you know your graders I
boarded the Raiders bus and then
everybody was sitting there looking at
me I said you ain't come on he said man
I ain't with that man I ain't with that
[Laughter]
hurry but ran off the bus true story man
I mean and it happens exactly that way I
mean after the game you know we're all
we're all really pissed off about the
game and you know everybody's heard my
clothes after the game you know it was
cool you know so I was I was mad man
because I felt like we were arrived
you know Raider Nation set we arrived
the team grew and everybody stuck we
arrived and of course but I'm not in the
mood to talk to anybody and tie
everybody knows that's very bad and it
was like I couldn't
couldn't even look at him and so I got
on the bus man and here he comes man he
steps up the steps to the front of the
bus man like time man come on bro we
doing it today they're like because he's
my boy you know what it means everybody
on the bus not only are they looking at
me like dude that was like that was the
insult to injury right there man that it
hurts so I mean it hurts so bad at the
moment because we we really had a really
great team we went there to New England
played in the snow you know coming from
California nobody say she's gonna be
able to play and and basically a
blizzard and we went out there we took
care of our business and you know what
we made the play to win the game and you
know they overturn the call of course
everybody knows then you know they go
down you know kick a field goal or
whatever and then they kick another
field going overtime hangs over that's
the way in so it is feeling like you
know no other game that I've been a part
of in my short career at that time and
so yeah I was hurt but that was time man
tired like that day is like that Charles
Woodson here on the Rich Eisen show I
was really here and now at the Raiders I
know you're obviously very tight with
them what can you share about Antonio
Brown with the fan base here of what
exactly happened there Charles
you know I feel like the the Oakland
Raiders really bent over backwards you
know to make things work there in
Oakland I mean there was a lot of things
that went on you know you could you had
the whole helmet situation you had you
know the cryotherapy
you know situation where all of a sudden
you couldn't practice yeah instances of
hell
you know just leaving and the Raiders
wanted to make it work you may use an
all world talent and you know when
you're a talented player in in in any
league you know you're afforded some
exceptions and so big they gave him
every exception that you could possibly
give a player expecting that he was
going to be a Raider and and then all of
a sudden you know the reports come out
about you know him in an altercation
with with the general manager and then
man he releases a video where he you
know tape recording conversations so of
course that you know it reached a level
to where it couldn't go any further than
that and so I mean that's kind of just
the way you know just recap it away it
went down but I know the Raiders they
bent over backwards that's to try to
have Antonio suit up in the silver and
black well I mean you know when people
get confused or they're there's no
answer for something you know obviously
that's when conspiracy theories come out
and the one that Antonio realized that
it wasn't gonna work there for whatever
reason and he did his best to go out
knowing that New England would be
sitting there for him and he
orchestrated the last few days I mean
Chris Mortensen even reported from your
former place of business you're now with
Fox Sports congratulations on that that
you bet that that that he sought out
methods to get himself out through
social media experts do you put any
credence in to the fact that he didn't
want to be there anymore and fought his
way out to New England
you know I think as you know as the way
things ended up it does seem a little
bit that way and and here's what I
here's what I base it on he had a whole
issue you know with the helmet you know
I want to wear my old helmet I can't
find a helmet you know this one doesn't
work this one doesn't work it's a little
working filing agreements with the NFL
all of a sudden you know he goes through
the problem with the GM and then you
know the tape and then all of a sudden
okay he's making all these noise about
all of these different things and then
he get to the way out of Oakland then he
goes to New England okay
so at that point Zenith the company the
helmet company they decide to break ties
with them have you heard anything about
that helmet since no like you wouldn't
you would assume if he's mad about
people who you know you know chastise
them or you know for lack of a better
word or people who don't want to deal
with them or he that he doesn't like or
you know severs ties wouldn't eat what
we've seen in the last three months he
lashes out I haven't heard anything from
him from anybody in his camp about him
having any problem with zena's let him
go and everything England I haven't
heard a thing
well maybe normally that just seems to
normally happen with New England right
that that somebody else is for the lack
of a better phrase problem player
becomes a model citizen once they're in
the the Patriot way system I mean you
were there you saw the Patriots I mean
did you sense any any boat rocking that
was going on involving number 17
formerly 84 on that day when you
personally were standing on the
sidelines I didn't see anything remotely
close to being out of order in New
England I mean they walked out there on
that field and they were a well-oiled
machine and the most interesting thing
to me as I'm sitting there on the
sidelines and the first you know he
didn't start the game with the guy in
the second places second play and they
went to him you know three out of five
three out of four times
but getting the ball and I just I
remember turning down turning around
talking to one of the producers and I'm
like this is Bill Belichick put the
middle finger up to everybody out there
they had a problem with it Neal Brown
going into to New England so I didn't
see any problems and though people were
speculating or talking about how
difficult the New England office was but
I see I saw him once run jet sweeps I
saw him run seen grouse I saw motion I
saw him shipped in and I saw a guy who
seemed like he was well versed in their
outfit so I think there's something to
it where he goes to New England and
Brady brings them in and they are going
over the offense and he's making sure
that Antonio Brown is ready to go out
there and play and it looked like he had
been there all training camp so I I
didn't see you know one iota of of a
problem with him being there and I think
you know with everything that's going on
you know he's just got he's gonna have a
fantastic year What's in New England
Patriots because we haven't heard
anything out of Charles Woodson here on
the Rich Eisen show fresh off again
being in Miami for the Patriots Dolphins
game for again epochs tonight 9:00
Eastern time for NFL the grind what
about the Dolphins Charles I mean so
much conversation that players veterans
are asking their agents to get out
because the team is flat-out tanking
what the front office is doing you can't
argue with the fact that they are
setting up for a 2020 draft despite
there's still 14 games left in the 2019
season you spoke with Minka Fitzpatrick
some of that video will be used tonight
what did you sense from this team
Charles yeah you know I looked at the I
was in the locker room and it just I
don't I don't think I know whether
they're coming or going at this point
you know you go into the season and you
know you talk about an Enka Fitzpatrick
was a guy who who played well for them
on the traffic there there's you know
you don't think of him being a guy
that's on the on the trading block but
you know these things kind of seem to
happen you know when do coaching staffs
come be an orgy ends come in
they come in you know not really caring
about who was there before them and you
know guys are speculating that all
Amanda's team is thinking about
rebuilding and their needle management
or coaches are come on and say no we're
not rebuilding then all of a sudden
because traded the during the time that
I was down at a couple of days
kingi and drank Kenyan Drake was all of
a sudden on a trading block and you know
they're stockpiling all of these draft
picks and sometimes I think as a player
you just want them to come out and say
hey yeah we're really group we are
rebuilding I mean they they're
stockpiling a bunch of draft picks for
next year and the years to come so you
know this is a team right now man I
think when I watched that game Sunday
they really came out fighting
you know I think they were embarrassed
the first game of the season obviously
I'm here to come to defending world
champs that just brought in another a
high-impact player to add to a team that
was already rolling and I they went out
there man and I really believed that
they fought but you know what rich
sometimes she just read it to a better
team and it was like a buzz so you know
they just you know the New England what
they do is they're just systematically
and methodically go down the football
field and they just put up points and
you know you look up at one point a game
and all of a sudden they they have 30
points you have no clue where those
points competition you know it came from
so for the Miami Dolphins those guys the
guys that are there you know they're
just gonna have to fight through his
period of time I mean this is going to
be a rough season I got a chance to you
know just speak to Xavier in Howard I've
spoke to her for the game and then also
after the game and I watched him play to
match them up on judge Josh Gordon and
he played a fantastic game on Gordon and
my thing was to him and this would be by
message to the entire Dolphins team as
well you know you got to put you just
got to put good film out there I mean
you understand all the noise that's
around the surrounding the team but you
can never let that affect how you play
as a person yeah during the week you
know you think about it and you're
singing you're sore and you're hurt but
once you get in there between the lines
on Sunday man you got to go out there
and do your job and Sapien is one guy
that I that I watched closely during
that game he's not going to quit on
Jimmy's gonna go out there and continue
to try to put film out there and I take
a lot of those guys are gonna do it as
well but like you mentioned you know
right now nobody knows who's gonna who's
gonna be on this team for the you know
for the duration that this season or the
next thing before I let you go your
thoughts on Eli Manning getting benched
you're obviously played against him you
know him what and we assume he's going
to be eventually in the same room you
will be in in Ohio one day what do you
think about the development to the
Giants Charles yeah I think this was an
obvious move plan I think once people
saw the young Daniel Jonathan in the
preseason and the way he kind of slung
up slung it around and all of the praise
that was kind of heaped on him you know
the way he came in and played in his
preseason I thought the writing was
gonna be on the wall if Eli didn't
really come out in you know really just
I think Eli was gonna have to come light
it up you know for them not to make the
change but I'd rather it happen like it
happened this time
you know a couple of weeks into the
season you got a new guy in that you're
trying to evaluate and get him playing
time and experience in the game I didn't
like the way they unceremoniously did it
the last time a couple of years ago when
they said oh well he's not going to
start but we make plan later in the game
that I didn't agree with but at this
point in time you know I think the
writing was on the wall that they
brought this young kid here to play I
think it was the obvious move and I
think it is gonna be the right move for
their team to see what they actually
have in that building Charles can't wait
for people to see your work on epics
tonight at 9:00 Eastern Time on NFL the
grind good luck with Fox Sports and I
appreciate the care package I received
here at the Rich Eisen show studio I
open it up there's two new bottles of
Charles Woodsen's wine called intercept
great name love the name love it and it
and and it tastes great Charles it's
it's it's some fine juice you're making
there sir well I hope you didn't expect
anything less rich oh come on now
Charles oh you know I love raising a
glass with you here you you only know
what you only know one speed Charles I
know that I hope so I hope so Charles
you're the best we'll chat again soon
you gotta go blue right back at you
that's Charles Woodson the go at Charles
Woodson on Twitter for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app